mais ils le disent à sa manière mais moi
il est extrêmement fier de moi je sais
pas pourquoi pas vous dit que vous étiez
un enfant dressage donc oui oui vous
travaillez bien l'école vous savez vous
comment mieux pour lui fallait que je
fasse des bêtises
ouais il fallait que je sois un bon
petit fils parce que c'est sa mère kim
élevé il fallait que je sois à mon gamin
à l'école pour pas qu'on fasse aux
carottes proche possible
moi j'étais pas non plus mais pas mais
est ce qui s qui est ce qu'il est arrivé
de vous demandez pas ce que vous aviez
fait une bêtise il m'a engueulé une
seule fois pourquoi samuel seule fois
parce que fournisseur d'os mobile est
allé avoir 14 ans donc là l'âge d'avoir
une mobylette
moi je voyais tout meetic panama rude et
cetera je dirai à mon père akoun
j'aimerais bien l'avoir une etc et je
sais pas pourquoi ma soeur et lui
avaient à peu monté la tête etc et il
signe un bungalow parleur que jamais il
m'avait engueuler quoi et dix minutes
après je le regarde un peu comme ça fait
ce n'est pas grave ça me plaît tu leur
as quand même
voilà bah ouais mais bon c'était une
petite wasmer moi moi c'est important je
m'étais jamais fait engueuler par un
père c'est 5 points à l'essence
il faisait peur ou pas non non pas du
monroe s'épanouir
oui nicolas y avait aucune règle et vous
aviez la peur la peur au ventre pour
votre papa non c'est ça oui et quelle
information vous arriviez à avoir de
temps qu'il était
c'est malheureux ce que je vais dire
mais tant qu'il était au quartier de
sécurité
il n'est pas inquiet en fait c'est ça
mais parce que je vais grandir c'est
magnifique et je ne vais pas dire qu'ils
étaient en sécurité
mais il est à haute sécurité donc voilà
les restait pas grand chose quelque part
par là les conditions de capitaux de
sécurité que tu es encore de sujet mais
quand il est en cavale
je me disais fait il ya quelques enfants
en cavale bien sûr on revient on retient
la dernière quand tu étais en cavale à
chaque cabane j'étais angoissé et 15
l'appartement de la famille il faut pas
enterrer des nouvelles même la route
grand verre vous aviez des nouveaux amis
anglais grand mère oui il arrivé à vous
à lui dire ça va on avait dû manière
d'une eau qui avait des contacts
d'accord vous allez contre oui oui
est-ce que vous avez vu les longs
métrages sur votre père notamment avec
vincent cassel oui je sais que vous
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé suis
même dedans même dedans vous avez vous
l'avez aimé vous l'avait adoubée non non
les deux les deux chiffres sont des très
bons
shi no numa ya pas photo vincent cassel
superbement voilà c'est vraiment super
film après historiquement ça reste du
cinéma les moments où il ya les petits
raccourcis les petites rues il ya un
conflit ce qu'on retrouve ce n'est pas
le vrai dans la réalité il ya une
voiture qui expose alors qu'il ya aucune
raison de faire exploser une voiture
alors que tout le monde leur recherche
voilà c'est un peu plus si les matraques
à l'annuler